today, I have both incredibly tremendous numbers
for Donald Trump coming up.
Um, uh, uh, in a sort of different context,
but also devastating numbers for Donald Trump.
So we're a year out from the election.
Yesterday we talked about how more than likely
this is going to be an election like most
elections that comes down to the results in
some key battleground States.
We looked yesterday at how Donald Trump is
fairing in particular States and head to head
match ups against the three front runners
in the democratic primary, Joe Biden, Elizabeth
Warren, and Bernie Sanders.
Fine.
Trump is doing a quite poorly in these battleground
States against Biden and Bernie, and he's
actually doing pretty well in those battleground
States against Elizabeth Warren.
However, let's at least briefly look at the
national numbers because if the national numbers
are even close to accurate, we could be heading
towards a historic election defeat for Donald
Trump.
So let's take a look.
Joe Biden in a hypothetical matchup is leading
Donald Trump nationally by 17 according to
a new Washington post poll, Elizabeth Warren
is leading Trump by 15 and Bernie Sanders
right in there leading Trump at 14.
Now, these are truly stunning numbers and
of course, we've not seen a popular vote victory
in a presidential campaign by 1415 or 17 for
a very, very long time.
Offhand, I don't remember when the last time
was.
According to the same poll, even mayor Pete,
Buddha, judge and Camila Harris are leading
Trump.
Uh, but not by as much.
So let's go through it piece by piece.
As I said yesterday, do I expect Donald Trump
to lose the popular vote in 2020 by 14 points
by 15 points, by 17 points?
I don't expect that, uh, I believe some people
who today say they would vote for a Democrat
will end up voting for Donald Trump either
out of fear or due to propaganda or incumbency
bias.
I believe that it is going to tighten and
indeed a lot of that lopsided popular vote
is going to end up coming out of big blue
States like California as we saw in 2016.
If you look at polling today in States that
are expected to be the difference makers,
we already looked at those numbers yesterday.
It is much tighter.
You're looking at four to six, you know, even
a much, much narrower margins.
But still, if the popular vote is uh, even
half as lopsided as this polling suggests,
we could have an unprecedented, unprecedented
defeat for Donald Trump in November of 2020.
But Donald Trump could also get himself reelected,
even losing the popular vote by three, four,
even five or six points.
There are models where Trump loses the popular
vote by five points, but still wins the electoral
college.
Although as you get to five six, seven, it
starts to become more and more unlikely that
you could lose the popular vote by so much
and still managed to win the electoral college,
but these are not numbers that anyone who
is on our side should be counting on or seeing
as a signal that we should relax and not worry
about the outcome because the let down that
was 2016 every single person should be voting
no matter where you vote.
Now, one good sign for the anti-Trump movement
is that if you look at the internals of how
this big rift between Trump and the democratic
front runners has opened up, of course, Democrats
overwhelmingly voting against Trump.
Of course, Republicans overwhelmingly voting
for Trump, but independence have been slowly
shifting away from Donald Trump, and that's
a good sign for the anti-Trump movement.
Republicans mostly love the guy.
Democrats mostly hate the guy and it's going
to be a turnout game, but independent voters
shifting to be more and more against Trump
is a bad sign for him in a good side for Democrats.
Lastly, we really need to not underestimate
that even if these numbers remain this way
for the next year, even if we get out the
vote, there can be another 11th hour comi
letter or you know, some equivalent to it.
Obviously it's not going to be comi in 2020,
but some equivalent to it.
The effect of strategic algorithmic online
advertising could be a difference maker.
Uh, the, um, voter suppression tactics that
are employed by Republicans at the state level.
So the real risk here is over confidence,
which could put Donald Trump in office for
another four years and what we need to do
in order to, uh, sort of sort of, uh, fight
back or overwhelm those factors that at the
last minute could help Donald Trump is turnout
on our side needs to be so high that none
of those things end up making a difference.
So register to vote, help other people registered
to vote, remind people to register to vote,
confirm that you are registered to vote.
If you believe that you are, report any registration,
irregularities, or voter purchase to both
the media and your local election officials.
Now, not October 29th not on election day
or the day before.
We've got to get on this now.
Um, and if all of these things come together,
then we may be able to remove Donald Trump
and you know, 17 points down in a poll to
a Joe Biden.
Who cares?
We don't need to win by 17 it doesn't matter
if we can trust those polls, we just need
to win.
And that is what the focus needs to be for
the next, I guess it's like 359 days or something
like that.
The countdown is very much on